on August 10 2015 Larry Page and Sergey  Brannon made Sundar piche the CEO of  Google at first glance it seemed like  the duo just wanted to play a more  hands-off role at the company if you  asked them at directly they'll tell you  that it was time to assume the role of  proud parents offering advice and love  but not daily Nagi but if you take a  closer look you'll see that there's more  to this than they let on it's not that  Larry and Sergey don't have visions for  Google or that they don't want to leave  the company rather they've founded that  every time they try to take the reins of  their company investors aren't  particularly happy and this wasn't the  one or two-time event it was a  consistent theme throughout their entire  time at Google and it seems that  eventually they came to accept that the  goals of Google and their own goals  simply did not align and instead of  trying to resist they did The Classy  thing and it truly stepped away